one guy has done his job very well
dolphins general manager chris greer
making trades stockpiling picks and
maybe more picks to be stockpiled if
they continue this hopscotch game
they're playing from three to 12 to six
could they trade down from six here's
greer talking about that possibility
i think uh
we'll always listen to everything we've
shown that and i think you ought to your
team and your organization to always
listen to any offers that
may or may not come and at the end of
the day you know as the draft falls and
gets towards our pick if you know
someone wants to call then and they make
an aggressive pitch to us we'll evaluate
it look at the board and look at our
options and we'll make the decision
that's best for the miami dolphins at
that point
you know peter when they traded to 12
and then moved back to six after being
in that third spot by virtue of the
laramie tunsil trade
the general consensus was and i was one
of the ones who reached this conclusion
in the moment well they're all in with
tuatanga viloa for 2021 but when you
look at where they are right now
and when you consider what we've just
discussed
bengals ain't taking a quarterback at
five i'm not going to trade out of that
spot to let someone else take one that's
just not who they are falcons at four if
they put kyle pitts on the card
the dolphins have their pick a trey
lancer justin fields at six and they're
a team that's holding their cards close
to the vest you know we're gonna have a
draft coming up in about 15 20 minutes
of all-time draft surprises would we not
call it a major surprise if they take
lancer fields they may have the chance
to do it and i can't rule out that they
will
that'd be the shock of shocks in this
draft i don't care who i don't care what
else happens in this draft if miami
takes quarterback
um
you know if they take a quarterback
fifth in the draft one year and then
sixth in the quote in the draft the next
year
man uh
that's uh
that's to me a bridge too far you've got
to give your quarterback a chance and
time especially because as you just saw
in that graphic can we see that graphic
one more time about the dolphins picks
i want you just to look at one thing
with this graphic
and that is not necessarily next year
they're in good shape next year not in
great shape but good shape but the
following year with two ones
what that can do for the dolphins in
2022 because figure this if they're
looking for a quarterback in 2022
they're not going to have had a very
good year this year let's say they're
gonna pick 13th next year in the draft
okay and there's their pick and then
you've got two ones the following year
to fool around with
now you have the ability if you're the
miami dolphins to go get your
quarterback next year if you take a
quarterback at six this year you ruin
tuatangavaloa it is over it's over
you've told him we don't think you're a
quarterback you might as well cut him
honestly
um and i i just i don't see it happening
or you could trade him for a second
round pick the way the dolphins gave up
a second round pick
to get josh rosen from the cardinals
after they went 10th overall one year
for rosen first overall the next year
for kyler murray so this kind of thing
isn't unprecedented what would be
different here is we're not talking
about the first overall pick we're
talking about the dolphins manipulating
the board to still come out of it
because they could have stayed at three
look if if they love lancer fields and
again they're not going to tell us if
they think lancer fields could come in
and be dramatically better than tool was
last year they're not going to admit it
but they could maybe look at this and
say all right we back out of three
because we think kyle shanahan wants mac
jones so lance and fields are still
going to be there now we get a chance to
get back to six and they did them all
together it wasn't like they did one
trade and then they did the next trade a
week or two later it was all one broader
transaction so before they knew they
were getting out of three they knew they
were getting back to six
and i just given the amount of thought
and effort and strategy that goes into
this draft i can't rule out the
possibility that they've worked out all
the scenarios and that they may end up
getting a quarterback that they secretly
love
fall to them at six and maybe if that
guy's there they take him and if not
they can trade down and get a receiver
skill position player later i just can't
close the door on it because we've seen
too many crazy things peter there was
once a team that took
quarterbacks
two quarterbacks in the first round in
the same year technically do you know
what i'm talking about
right the dallas cowboys steve walsh
exactly aikman
so i i can't when it comes to the
quarterbacks
of the quarterback position
you're giving up your first round pick
for next year and that would have been a
high first round pick because they were
one in 15.
think about that 1989 they make troy
aikman the first overall pick and they
would have been in position again for
another high pick
uh my point is this in the first place
we know how yeah
go ahead
i was just gonna say i don't think miami
would have ever traded down from three
if they were seriously thinking about
taking a quarterback because
seriously
you know
if you're gonna like one of those guys
if you trade from three to 12 and then
even coming back to six
okay
there's a good chance you're going to
have one quarterback left at number six
and you don't know who that is what if
you say oh man we love justin fields why
would you make that trade if you want to
take justin fields because you have no
idea if justin fields on march 29 is
going to be there
there's one explanation
okay
and i think it's pretty simple and it
would explain why they did these moves
together 3 to 12 12 to 6 boom boom rapid
fire
if they both
or if they love both guys lance and
fields if you make the assessment jones
is the guy that shanahan's going to take
or if you love all three if you've done
that you can't make that assess
what if they made that make that
assessment at that time
you can't you can't make the in the only
way to me that if you're if you're miami
and you love a quarterback
i mean
do you love three of them
i mean that's the only way you can
handle the pair
let's move
well
we'll find out i i would tend to doubt
that
i don't i don't believe that i don't
think he loves three enough to ruin his
next two drafts
uh to move up to take one but we'll see
we'll see i i i just have my doubts
about that
well i my point is shanahan loves
lawrence wilson and whoever he takes
because there is
when you're at three
two of the other guys are going to be
gone and by now we know we weren't 100
sure a month ago that it was going to be
wilson two to the jets but my point is
this
and and i think we we need to take a
step back and look at what happened last
year what did what did brian flores do
multiple times last year with his rookie
quarterback he benched him he benched
him for ryan fitzpatrick during a game
instead of letting the guy finish it was
get this guy the hell off the field now
he did in a very tactful way he never
had a locker room problem i think brian
flores is on his way to becoming a great
head coach because he manages his team
incredibly well and doesn't have a bunch
of a bunch of leaks and discontent and
schisms in the locker room but hey uh
i look i know hey who knows where the
ceiling is on tour but flores has had a
whole year to work with him now and i'm
just saying we can't rule out the
possibility that flores and greer have
decided whether it's jones lance and
fields or whether it's just lansing
fields huge upgrade over tua we need our
franchise guy we've got all the other
pieces in place we're gonna go for it i
i'm just i'm not saying it's gonna
happen
i'm just saying that we've seen enough
crazy crap go down over the years that
we can't just say there's no way it'll
happen
i can say it
there's no way it'll happen
see i just takes exposed old tanks
exposed alert alert alert
freezing cold takes get ready mark this
moment 8 23 a.m eastern on friday the
23rd of april
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports